back to brexit and the Chancellor today
will outline just how much bricks it
will cost the country one report this
morning claims that the economic impact
of a No Deal brexit could cost the UK
economy 150 billion pounds a year while
the Prime Minister's proposed deal comes
at a reported cost of 40 billion pounds
a year well let's go to Westminster now
or we can have a chat with a chance that
Philip Hammond good morning to you and I
just will have a look at the front page
of The Daily Mail today a poll of voters
saying that 41 percent of them would
back Theresa Mays brexit deal 52 percent
think is the best deal on offer it's the
financial analysis from the Treasury
today going to back that up
well first of all it's a financial
analysis that's been done across
Whitehall by the civil service at the
request of parliament and it'll be
published to Parliament later on and
what I can tell you is that it will show
that a No Deal exit will have a much
higher cost impact on the economy than
the deal that the Prime Minister has
negotiated which gives us the benefits
of political benefits of being out of
the European Union with very little
economic costs that's why we have
negotiated this deal in the way we have
because we believe that our job has been
to deliver the exit from the European
Union that the British people voted for
but to do it in a way that protects our
economy protects British jobs and
protects British business but this
analysis is going to show that the UK
economy is going to take a hit do all
scenarios outlined in this analysis
leave us worse off than staying in the
EU if you look only at the economic
costs and benefits yes there will be a
cost to leaving the European Union
because it makes our trade less fluid
and it cuts us from an important export
market it creates some level of barriers
the important thing is to minimize those
barriers as far as we can and to keep
trade flowing as much as we can and what
the analysis
mario's are going to leave us worse off
so in all scenarios in in pure economic
terms there is a cost what the analysis
shows is that the deal the Prime
Minister has negotiated is by far the
best outcome for the economy and that
while getting the political benefits of
being out of the European Union the
economic costs of that are very minimal
in the deal that the Prime Minister has
negotiated it's interesting though
because you do have to wonder did people
vote to be poorer when they look at this
analysis what are they going to think
because for the UK economy to be buoyant
and sustained what it's doing now it
should stay in the EU is that what this
report is going to show us no the UK
economy is buoyant and and fundamentally
strong and we'd just be better off
staying inside the European well let me
be clear the UK economy will grow
outside the European Union and it will
continue to grow because of its
fundamental strengths it's very strong
high-tech industry our very important
services sector our global companies all
of those things will keep the UK economy
growing but the economy will be in in in
any of these scenarios a little bit
smaller than it would have been if we'd
remained inside the European Union I'm
the Chancellor of course I have to look
at the economic impacts but I readily
accept that it is not only the economy
that influences people they will be
looking at other aspects of the package
the benefits of being able to operate an
independent trade policy of having
control of our fishing waters for
example so there are other aspects as
well the important thing about this
report today is that it informs
Parliament it provides information so
that my colleagues in Parliament when
they're making their decisions about how
to vote on December the 11th can be
properly and fully informed well you are
the Chancellor you endorsing this
analysis coming out this afternoon was
your assessment of the impact of the
Prime Minister's deal on our economy so
the deal that the Prime Minister is
negotiated and the analysis will show
that has a minimal impact on the UK
economy
something that we can easily can you
figure on it's being reported at forty
billion pounds a year I'm not I'm not
going to put a figure on it because it's
right that we publish that this
information to Parliament Parliament
requested it we've produced it for
Parliament and I think it's would be
disrespectful to Parliament for me to
come on the television this morning and
start talking about the figures but what
I can say is that it will show that in
the Prime Minister's negotiated deal the
impact on our economy would be very
small indeed so we're gaining the
benefits of exiting the European Union
without risking the future of our
economy if we were to leave the moneyman
because we are talking economics today i
mean we talk about so many different
factors of brexit but today it's purely
about the economics could you say that
categorically this stay in the EU would
be better for the UK economy in the long
term because this analysis today is
going to show that every other scenario
whether it is the Prime Minister's deal
no deal or a Canada style deal will all
leave us worth to solve whether it's a
hundred fifty billion or forty billion a
year well look the first rule of
economics is that you can t isolate
economics from the rest of the world and
we've had a referendum we've made a
decision to leave the European Union so
that is what we are going to do if we
were to some in some way renege on that
decision we would leave our country
fractured in a way that would deeply
damage our economy divided countries are
not successful countries and that the
point about the Prime Minister's deal is
that it will allow us to come together
as a country those who passionately want
to leave the European Union will get
there which we will be out of the
European Union and out of its structures
those who are concerned about our trade
and our economic relationship with
Europe will be assured that we will
continue to have a very close trading an
economic and security relationship with
Europe and I hope it will be the
catalyst to start bringing the country
back together again the Prime Minister
has been very clear we are leaving the
EU but what isn't clear is whether this
deal will make it through pom and the
big question people want the answer to
is
what happens if this deal doesn't make
it through what next well look the Prime
Minister's deal has plenty of critics
but what I haven't heard yet is anybody
with a credible alternative plan this is
the best negotiated deal that is
available from the European Union and if
it is not passed by Parliament we will
be in quite literally unknown territory
we'll be going back to square one and
Parliament politicians will have to sit
down and decide where we go next but our
focus for the next two weeks will be on
selling this deal to the British people
explaining the benefits of it explaining
how to the British people you should be
selling it to the MPs you need to vote
for it you're selling it to the people
that would imply that you're holding
your hands up and saying at some point
there is going to be a second referendum
and we need to get voters onside no not
at all I think that is to misunderstand
how parliamentarians work and operate
parliamentarians are elected to
represent the their constituents and
they do listen whatever people might
think parliamentarians do listen to what
their constituents are saying to them
where public opinion is going and of
course we'll be talking to our
parliamentary colleagues but we also
need to talk to the people of this
country and explain why this is the best
way forward to deliver on the commitment
to leave the European Union but to do it
in a way that will protect British jobs
British businesses and British
prosperity going forward and I am
absolutely convinced that the Prime
Minister's deal is the best way to take
the British economy forward while
leaving the European Union prime
minister is a busy woman at the moment
she's trying to convince the public
she's trying to convince MP she's off to
a g20 summit
she's also promised to debate the brexit
deal with Jeremy Corbyn has she set a
date for that when will she do it well
we've said we've set out the challenge
to Jeremy Corbyn the Prime Minister has
challenged him to a debate it's for him
to respond now and then of course for
the broadcasters to make the detailed
arrangements how about the 9th I'm
looking at my diary that's the date
that's been suggested I'm freeing you
well that suits you does it ok I'll let
the Prime Minister know that's a good
one for you
okay that's pretty an in pencil for now
just in pencil yeah reports today
suggesting that the Prime Minister's
going to refuse to publish in for the
legal advice behind her deal well she
published that legal advice because
Jacob Riis Morgan's come out today and
said look she promised to do that it was
requested by Humble address and to not
publish it in full would be
unconstitutional on the contrary it's
the other way around we will publish a
summary of the legal advice but the
clear constitutional in for why summary
well I'll just explain that now the
clear constitutional precedent in this
country is that the advice of the
Attorney General to the government is
private and that has to be the case if
government is going to be able to
function properly the government has to
have access to private legal advice so
that it can make decisions which are
properly made and indeed so that it can
ensure that it complies with its legal
obligations and if we started publishing
the advice of the Attorney General to
government we would find that government
could not operate freely and could not
obtain the legal advice that it needs in
order to navigate ordinary processes of
government a couple of last questions
for you cuz I know you've got busy day
ahead and the penultimate one what
preparations are happening for no deal
because there's a report this morning a
parliamentary report that has said the
secrecy and shortcomings in the
preparations for a no deal by the
government are potentially toxic
combination we're running a report today
showing that port authorities say the
Department of Transport are leaving it
all a bit late and it could cause chaos
well look there's a balance to be struck
isn't that we've got to prepare for the
contingency of an Odile exit there is a
possibility that that could happen so
it's right that we're planning it's
right that we're spending money but
equally we don't think that this is a
likely outcome even though we have to
prepare for it as a possibility and
people would rightly ask after the event
whether we've been cautious in the way
we've spent public money in preparing
for something that more than likely will
never happen so there is a balancing act
I think we've got it about right
we don't want to panic people
unnecessarily we don't want to spend
taxpayers money unnecessarily but we do
want to do the things that are vitally
important to have been done if we were
to find ourselves in a no deal scenario
okay well we've got you as the nation's
money man I'm looking for a definitive
answer from you this morning on
something that's really been dividing
sky news viewers this morning and that
is who pays for Christmas dinner are you
hosting this year and would you ask
relatives for a contribution because
let's face it if you hosting up to 10
people it could be pretty pricey well no
I wouldn't ask relatives for a financial
contribution but my experience is that
when you host a lunch party or a dinner
party very often people bring you know
bottle of wine bottle of whiskey or
something with them so people people
often will bring you know contributions
in kind I think that's a nicer way to do
it than asking people for cash well Mr
Hammond you might want to change your
mind this year because I hear food
prices are going up if there's a No Deal
saturate well if there's no deal it's
quite likely that there would be a
negative impact on food prices we import
a lot of food including a lot of food
from the European Union in a no deal
scenario we could expect the cost of
that to increase YUM
okay well what a No Deal and the deal
isn't around yet we can spend a bit of
cash on our loved ones and host them for
Christmas dinner that's the definitive
answer from the money man of the nation
mr. Philip Hammond of the Chancellor
thank you very much thank you Philip
Hammond thank you